احنا هوا
يا ماندو
يلا بينا
نحن على الهواء
مساء الخيرات على حضراتكم وايام سعيده
مباركه ونسال الله انه في هذه الايام
المباركه ان يحل السلام على السودان واهله
على كل مناطق النزاع اللي بتعاني ماسي في
العالم العربي وفي كل دول العالم
احنا موضوعنا الرئيس طبعا النهارده على
السودان والاسئله جاءت سريعا واتمنى انه
ربنا يوفقنا ونقدر نجاوب على جزء منها
اول سؤال جاي من صديقنا محمد عبد الحليم
الدول التي يمكنها التدخل العالم كله
يمكنه التدخل يا صديقنا ولكن الدول
المعنيه بالصراع
تقدر تقسمها كده الدول اللي هي دول الجوار
المباشر للسودان السودان لو بصيت للخريطه
هتجد ان في السبع دول لها حدود مباشره مع
السودان مصر ليبيا
تشاد جنوب السودان اريتريا اثيوبيا وطبعا
جنوب السودان دول مضطره للتدخل بدرجات
مختلفه
في الدول كمان تقدر تعتبرها مناطق جوار
اللي هي دول اللي موجوده في الجزيره
العربيه وتحديدا السعوديه ودول خليجيه
نشطه زي الامارات مثلا
هي بتتشاطا مع السودان في من خلال البحر
الاحمر السعوديه هي الاقرب طبعا هي واليمن
مضطره للتدخل
انا قلت في دول الجوار اثيوبيا اظن
وفي الدول اللي هي الاقليميه القويه يعني
زي ايران زي تركيا زي اسرائيل والدول
الكبرى بتتكلم على روسيا بتتكلم على
الولايات المتحده صين الولايات المتحده كل
دي الدول عندها مصالح كثيره وان شاء الله
نعرض من خلال اسئلتكم على المصالح هذه
الدول في السودان الدول الاقرب الى الرغبه
في التدخل او الاضطرار للتدخل هتلاقي
بالاضافه لدول الجوار المباشر اللي على
راسها طبعا هتكون مصر واثيوبيا كل الدول
الحقيقه يعني اللي موجوده هتجد انه
الامارات السعوديه
والدول الكبيره اللي انا اشارتها
اخونا اي ام اي اي الطرفين في السودان
اقرب للنظام السابق سؤال مرورك والله
العظيم لانه من عجائب وغرائب السودان
انه مش عارف ليه بيحضرني كلمه كان قالها
شكسبير في مسرحيه مكبس في مطلع المسرحيه
كده والساحرات الشريرات
بيقراوا مستقبل مكبث اللي هو القائد
العسكري اللي راجع منتصر من الحرب
وبيقولوا له عباره لا انساها ولا تلميذ
قالتها يعني فارس فعلا
الحق باطل والباطل الحق الامور مختلطه جدا
في السودان الجيش السوداني المفروض ان كل
الاطراف اللي موجوده على الساحه يفترض
انها جاءت على انقض نظام هي بتمثل المفروض
نظريا القوى اللي هي صارت عليه او على
الاقل بتعبر عن القوى اللي صارت عليه ده
غير صحيح وده مش غريب في السودان يعني
الكلام ده حصل في مصر الكلام ده حصل في
عشرات الدول اللي حصلت فيها ثروات الثورات
عاده النظم اللي كانت قائمه بتكون اسرع
للعوده من القوى الثوريه
انما الجيش المفروض
انه يعني
انه اولا مؤسسه مهنيه لكن حقيقه الامر
الجيش متهم بانه مخترق من النظام السابق
او جبهه الانقاذ او الجبهه القوميه
الاسلاميه وطبعا ده قصه معروفه للسودانيين
انه على مدار سنوات طويله الضباط
السودانيين اللي هم كثير منهم متدين
بطبيعته كان كتير منهم جاء بحكم ترشيح من
اسر محسوبه على جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
وبالتالي من هذا الزاويه فهو بعض بيعتبروا
انه فصيل منه على الاقل او في تيار بيعبر
عن النظام القديم في نفس الوقت قوات الدعم
السريع هي اصلا صنيعه البشير وحمضتي هو
كان رجل البشير الذي انقلب عليه
كمان هو
يعني رغم انه حاول او هو متهم بجرائم حرب
في دارفور ومتهم بالوقوف في محاوله
ارتكاب مجازر في 19 في يونيو
2019 الى انه الرجل بيقدم نفسه على انه هو
وجه السودان المضيء اللي يرغب فيه
بيعبر عن رغبه السودانيين في الانتقال
السريع للديمقراطيه وفي نفس الوقت هو متهم
من الجيش بانه هو
فتح السجون
ويعني اقتحمها علشان يفرج عن انصار النظام
السابق ونفس التهمه دي بيتهمها قوات الدعم
السريع للقوات المسلحه فالامر بالغ
للاختلاط والغموض في السودان ومره تانيه
هذا ليس امرا غريبا في المرحله اللي
بتعيشها السودان
[موسيقى]
اخونا اشرف بيقول والله جميله اشرف ان انت
كتبت اسمك في الاول بدل ما تعذب بقراءه
الحروف الاولى من الاسامي بالانجليزي يعني
كتر خيرك يا اشرف
اذا ارادوا هل تملك اي من الدول العربيه
لوبي او جامعات ضغط على اماكن صنع القرار
في الدول العظمى على غرار اللوبي
الاسرائيلي
واذا واذا لا فلماذا لا طبعا دول عندها
لوبيات
على غرار اللوبي الاسرائيلي ولكن ليس بقوه
الله بالاسرائيلي مستحيل اي دوله
تملك لوبي مثل اللوبي الاسرائيلي لقصه اذا
اردت ان تعرفها بالتفصيل فاستاذنك ان تعود
الى حلقه بعنوان لماذا يخاف الرؤساء
الامريكان من اسرائيل
اجتهدت في ان انا ابذل جهد استغرق مني وقت
واتمنى اكون وفقت في سبب النفود
الاسرائيلي على امريكا بس ده مش موضوعنا
انما الدول العربيه تعلمت امور كثيره جدا
منها ان يكون عندها السعوديه بتتعاقد مع
شركات ضغط وبتتعاقد مع رجال كونجرس وبتعمل
لهم رواتب
الامارات قطر دول كثيره المصريين عندهم
اقول لك على حاجه الفريق حميتي عنده شركه
علاقات عامه
هي الشركه في كندا لكنها بتنشط ايضا في
اماكن اخرى من العالم
وبتحاول ان هي تسوق وجهات نظره في وسائل
الاعلام العالميه فاذا ردا على سؤالك
الدول العربيه مختلفه عندها لوبيات بتحاول
تضغط بها على صناع القرار في امريكا وفي
اوروبا وفي غيره انما ليس طبعا بقوه
الاسرائيلي
علي محمد كلنا نعرف
اليكوهين كيف وصل لاعلى المناصب في سوريا
اه والله
اليكوهين ده قصه جميله بس ما ذكرك يا
صديقنا بهذا
امال بتقول امال الخطيب لم نكن في السابق
لنتعاطف مع اسرائيل ولكن بعد الربيع
العربي ورؤيتنا ما يمكن لحكامنا القيام به
بحق من مذابح للبقاء في السلطه وهم ابناء
وهم ابناء جلدتنا لم نعد نستطيع لم نعد
نستعظم جرائم الاحتلال
امل والله امر مؤسف انا انا بقول لاصدقائي
هنا يعني مش متابع او الشان السوداني
ناس خلاصيه كل يوم كل يوم فبقت التغطيه
بقت ايه الناس بتدور على خبر تاني زي اي
صراع يحظى بالاهتمام وبعدين الناس بتدور
بقى على على خبر ثاني يعني بقول لهم انتم
مش متخيلين الوضع في السودان انه انه مش
حر مش زي الحروب الكثيره اللي شاهدها
السودان منذ سنه 56 ده حرب عجيبه غريبه ان
هي في قلب المدن يعني حد يبقى قاعد في قلب
المدينه المستشفى اللي جنبه المدرسه اللي
جنبه البيت بيضرب فشيء ما كانش متصور انه
يشتبكوا مع بعض لكن في قلب المدن
اي الطرفين في السودان ده ايه ده سائد قبل
اقرب الى تسليم السلطه الى المدنيين ولا
واحد فيهم طبعا
حتى لو عاملها تبقى مساله مؤقته يعني لكن
لا
كيف سمحت امريكا للنظام السوري على فكره
هم مش عاوزين يسلمهم المدنيين ولا دول
كبيره مؤثره حريصه انهم يسلموا للمدنيين
موضوع المدنيين دي ممكن يعني ايه يبقى في
طبعا حكومه مدنيه حصل انه زي ما حصل ايام
عبد الله حمدوك ولكن تظل السلطه ومفاصيلها
طبعا تحت ايديهم ومستعدين ان يهبوا
لاستردادها اذا هددت التصوراتهم لكيفيه
تسير الامور
كيف سمحت امريكا للنظام السوري بالبقاء
رغم تجر رغم تجرئه عليها
بحرب العراق عندما ادار شبكه جهاديين
ارسلهم مزبوط الكلام ده من سوري الى
العراق حدث الكلام ده انا
وقايد هذه الشبكه مع امريكا بملف الحريري
لغد
يعني يمكن انا مش قادره اشوف كويس بس انا
فهمت وجهه نظرك يعني هو فعلا اعمل شبكه
جهاديين وهاجم المصالح الامريكيه
بعد غزوهم في العراق هذا كلام سليم انت
بتقول كيف تجرا او ليه هم سابوا النظام
السوري هم ما نسبوش النظام السوري انت
عندك نقطتين طبعا ده خارج موضوعنا لكن
احترام لحضرتك احنا هنتكلم عليه يعني
امريكا في تعاملها مع سوريا زي ما تعاملها
مع ملفات كتيره بتبقى عندها اولويات
متناقده يعني مثلا
تتمنى من وجهه نظر ان هي تطيح ببشار الاسد
لانه واحد اتنين تلاته ومن واحد اتنين
تلاته اللي انت قلت عليه لكن من ناحيه
تانيه تيجي تقول طب البديل ايه اذا كان
هذا النظام محقق نوع من التوازن يعني هو
لا يصل بالصراع مع اسرائيل الى حد
المواجهه الجبهه مستقره وما فيش مشاكل مع
اسرائيل لا تستطيع ان تستوعبها انه
العلاقاته في معظم الوقت مع الدول العربيه
ما فيش فيها ازمه عنيفه انه عنده مصالح مع
ايران مثلا الروس لكن لا يهدد المصالح
الامريكيه بشكل لا يستطيع يعني الا
يتحملوا نقطه توازن ثم ما هي البدائل اصلا
اضف الى ذلك بقى انه الكلام ده لما كان
امريكا مهتمه امريكا بقى لها سنوات في دول
يعني هي مثلا لما تيجي تقرا استراتيجيات
امريكا واولادها في المناطق تلاقي دول
ساقطه منها خالص مثلا السودان اللي هو
موضوعنا ليس من اوليات الخارجيه الامريكيه
خالص سوريا ليس من اولويات السياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه خالص لما بتكون دوله
ما عندهاش امريكا ما لهاش فيها سياسه يعني
حساسيه قوي بالنسبه لها لا تمثل موضعا
حساسا بتتركها الحلفائها وحلفائها مختلفين
تركيا حليف اسرائيل دول الخليج حليف فيعني
اي
في حل صعود اي قوه عظمى جديده على حساب
امريكا مثل الصين هل ستنقل اسرائيل اللوبي
الصهيوني اليها وتصبر وستصبح تلك الدوله
المنحازه لاسرائيل ايضا
هي عامله كده بالفعل هي بدات علاقات بتقوي
علاقتها جدا مع الصين
بشكل متزايد
وحريصه ان هي تقوي علاقتها اصل المساله
بدات قبل امريكا يعني من اولويات دايما
من الفكر يعني من اساسيات الفكر الصهيوني
انه دايما يكون في دوله عظمى هو بيعتمد
على دعمها
يسعى للدوله العثمانيه يسعى لالمانيا ده
يعني في بدايه الحركه الصهيونيه يسعى
لبريطانيا ثم يسعى الى الولايات المتحده
يكون حريص على ارضاء الروس يكون حريص على
ارضاء القوه الصاعده زي الصين فكلام حضرتك
الاجابه المختصره نعم بس مش معناها انه
يعضد علاقته بالصين انه يفسد علاقته
بالامريكان يعني
ما عندوش سبب يجعله يجعل يدفعه لذلك
ماذا ما يحدث في السودان ان يبقى ما يحدث
في السودان لن يبقى في السودان هل من
الممكن ان تتدخل مصر العسكريا في السودان
في ظل تصريحات الدعم السريع المبطن ضد مصر
ممكن جدا جدا وانا الحقيقه سجلت حلقه ولكن
الحلقه يعني لقيتها طويله قوي بعد ما
سجلتها فعلى الارجح احاول اختصرها شويه
وفعلا ما يبقى ما يحدث في السودان لا يبقى
في السودان لانه بينزاح على الدول الاخرى
وده ما ينطبش على السودان بس ولكن ينطبق
على على دول اخرى على كل الدول يعني
وبالتالي انت بتقول ممكن مصر اه ممكن مصر
تتدخل سرا او عالما اذا وجدت انه المساله
يعني بتضرب مصالحها في بشكل كبير
اذا وجدت ان امنها المائي مهدد اذا وجدت
موجات خطيره من الهجره بتهددها اذا هددت
الملاحه في البحر الاحمر وبالتالي هدرت
قناه السويس احد الموارد الاقتصاد
الاساسيه للاقتصاد المصري اذا وجدت انه
الفوضى او
استباد النظام في السودان تحت حكم حكومه
او رئيس لا يراعي مصالح المصريين حاجات
كتيره يمكن ان تدفعهم للحرب
وبعدين ما مصر مجرد للصراع اللي كان موجود
في ليبيا يعني ما هيش احنا مش بنتكلم على
التاريخ البعيد ولا حاجه وجدت ان هي مش
هتقدر تنتظر كده داخل الحدود وتراقب
الموقف في ليبيا
[موسيقى]
بصمت يعني ما ينطبق على مصر ينطبق على اي
دوله تانيه
عربي دراما بيقول
استاذنا لقد زرت عده دول منها تركيا لوجهه
السياحه للسياحه يعني
لو ان مصر تعمل بشكل جدي في ملف السياحه
تستطيع ان تقفز باقتصادها الان لديها
مقاومات سياحيه نادره وتكلفه رخيصه يجب ان
يكون هذا اهم ملف لدى حكومتكم والله يا
ايدك انه هذا ملف متاح ما انتاش محتاج
مثلا
انك تعمل يعني
تغييرات عميقه علشان تطور قطاع الصناعه
ولا قطاع الزراعه ممكن تبذل جهدا في تطوير
قطاع السياحه ولكن من الامور المحزنه جدا
وبالصدفه انت بتكلمني في ملف وكنت بكلم
صديق ليا من العاملين في السياحه شيء محزن
ان في امور مشاكل في قطاع السياحه المصري
موجوده كل ما اسال عنها عده سنوات اجدها
لم تتغير ابدا
مش عارف يعني يعني اتمنى ان هم يقولوا
مقطاع السياحه لان هو مش محتاج مش محتاج
جهد كبير قوي زي القطاعات الاخرى
كيف لكم كيف لكم الجهل الموجود في المجتمع
العربي ان ينتج ديمقراطيه وتقدم ولو نسبه
كيف لكمل جهل الموجود لما ينتجش يا صديقي
يعني انت اخوكم انا اسف مش عارفه اقرا
الاسم
بس لا الكهل او نقص التعليم والفقر لا
ينتج ديمقراطيه طبعا في حلقه بعنوان
استاذنك يعني
عنوانها
هل يكره العرب الديمقراطيه ام انهم غير
مستعدين لها استاذنك ان تعود اليها
ويعني خلاصتها كده لا يعني ديمقراطيه لها
شروط وبالتالي كثير من الدول العربيه غير
مؤهل لها بصراحه يعني
كيف هل الدول مخيره
مجبره ام هي محكومه بالتاريخ والجغرافيا
والموارد والظروف بمعنى اخر لو تبادلت
اسرائيل وفلسطين الادوار فهل سيكون
الفلسطينيين اكثر اكثر رحمه من
الاسرائيليين
انا رايي مش هتفرق كتير يعني هي يعني لو
نفس الوضع اللي هم في الاسرائيليين هيبقى
نفس القصه نفس القصر اصل انت ايه وضع
الاسرائيلي الاسرائيلي واخد ارض مش بتاعته
عدد سكان صغير محاط
يعني مش ملايين مئات الملايين من عرب
ومسلمين بل ومسيحيين عرب وغيرهم هم لا
يتعاطفون الغالبيه العظمى الكاسحه لا
يتعاطف معه
وبالتالي هو فلسفته يعني ان انا اذا لم
اكن اقوى بكثير جدا من كل هؤلاء مجتمعين
لو لم اظهر قدر كبير جدا من القسوه انا مش
هقدر احقق اطماعي فيها لو ان اي حد في
مكان اسرائيل وبغى بغيهم واستولى على
اراضي غيره وعارف انه وجوده بس مرهون
بالقوه ما اعتقدش انه يستخدم اساليب رحيمه
يعني
انما انت ممكن توسع السؤال يعني مثلا احنا
بنشتكي من الولايات المتحده ونفاقها
ومعايرها المزدوجه هل نفس الكلام ينطبق
على دول اخرى اذا حلت محل الولايات
المتحده الاجابه نعم نفس القصه
التعاون العسكري الاخير بين طالبان
والولايات المتحده ما دلالاته ما اعرفش ان
في تعاون عسكري
بالمعنى اللي ممكن اقول عليه التعاون
عسكري بين طالبان والولايات المتحده لو
عندك معلومه قولي عليها انا مش عارف قصدك
ايه بالتعاون العسكري لكن لغايه ما انت
تبعت لي انه اي يعني الولايات المتحده
تعاونت مع ايران مثلا في عز يعني بعقاب
ازمه الرهائق مباشره
ايران تعاونت مع صدام حسين في اثناء
الازمه اسرائيل وايران تعاون
يعني
فكره انه يكون عندك علاقه سيئه جدا مع
دوله مش معناه ان مفيش علاقات انت مضطر
تتعامل مع كل الناس طالبان جماعه بتحكم
منطقه جغرافيه للناس اللي حواليها مصالح
فما المانع ان تتعاون معاها امريكا بس ايه
التعاون العسكري بقى يعني اديتها اسلحه
مثلا هل ساعدتها على تامين حدودها ايه
يعني ايه اللي تقصده بالتعاون العسكري
لو الغرب دعم المعارضه السوريه بالسلاح
الكافي هو الحلقه النهارده ايه عن سوريا
احنا مش عن السودان يا شباب السودان بلد
مهم لو الغرب دعم لمعارض السوريه بالسلاح
الكافي لغرقت روسيا وايران في سوريا اما
ان الغرب احمق وانه اوهم روسيا بانتصارها
في سوريا عن عبد الله يجعل
ليجعلها تقترب بنفسها وتدخل اوكرانيا
لغايه في نفس يعقوب والله انا ما يعني
بس انا لا اتفق معها انا اشك جدا جدا جدا
في الروايه اللي دايما بتصور الولايات
المتحده او غيرها ان هي عندها تصور كامل
للعالم وان هي بتلعب شطرنج ما بتلعبش
شطرنج ولا حاجه ده هي متخبطه
هي وغيرها يعني الملفات كثيره والمسؤوليات
ضخمه
وادارات متعاقبه
ومزيان ناس متخيلين دوله مؤسسات وهو بيخطط
لمئه سنه هذا كلام يعني انا اختلف معاه
يعني لكن هي لو دعمت المعارضه السوريه
بالسلاح
وروسيا وايران دعمت الرئيس بشار الاسد
بالسلاح كانت المجازر برضو هي حصلت مجازر
كارت المجازر هتبقى اضعاف يعني
وكان اذا كان الروس بيمدوا مثلا اسلحه
متوسطه وتقليديه كان هيمد باسلحه اعنف
وكان الايرانيين هيمدوا
بامدادات اكثر خطوره وهكذا يعني
فكل واحد بيقول انا لغايه فين يعني لان
انت انا اعرف مثلا معلوفه ان الروس لما
دخلوا سوريا
الروس بيدعموا المعارضه الروس قالوا لهم
ادعموهم يعني انت ما اقدرش تمنعهم انما
اذا عرفت انه انتم امديتوا اي معارض سوري
باسلحه يمكن ان تهدد طيراننا فهيكون
العواقب وخيمه عليكم لما الروس يقولوا كده
معناه ايه معناها ان هم هيمدوا دول اخرى
تهدد مصالح الامريكان وحلفائهم باسلحه
اكثر خطوره يمد ايران على سبيل المثال يمد
الجماعات المعارضه في العراق اللي هي
التابعه لايران وهكذا كان ممكن وقتها في
2015 قبل عمليه الانسحاب يمد طالبان
فيعني بتحصل عمليه التوازنات بين القوى
الكبرى
ما مصلحه الامارات ودول اخرى من تمويل
الرد
الدعم السريع مش الرد السريع وهل تعتقد ان
هناك اياد خارجيه ساهمت بتاجيج الصراع بين
الجيش
يعني تحياتي لشخصكم الكريم ولماندو
ده اخونا هاني مصلحه الامارات يا صديقي زي
مصلحه بتشترك مع دول الخليج في مجموعه من
الاهداف وعندها هي اهداف خاصه بها كل دول
الخليج باعتبارهم جيران للسودان عندهم
مصلحه في عمليه استثمار اولا هم استثمروا
بسخاء في الاراضي الزراعيه السودانيه
ليه استثماره في الاراضي الزراعيه
السودانيه هم استثمروا في الاراضي
الزراعيه في كل افريقيا وفي دول امريكا
اللاتينيه ودول اخرى لانه دول الخليج دول
غنيه نعم ولكنها تعاني من شح مائي فكان
احد التصورات ان هي تستثمر تشتري مياه
واراضي دول اخرى
وتستثمرها لصالحها ده اولا بس هم استثمروا
بكميات كبيره جدا يعني السعوديه لغايه
2015 16 كانت استثمرت
بحوالي 13 مليار دولار ده رقم ضخم
الامارات كذلك قطر كذلك الكويت كذلك دول
كثيره ودول غير خليجيه زي مثلا الاردن
فعندها مصالح زراعيه اثنين
ده كده ده كده مشتركه فيه مع دول الخليج
الاخرى اثنين ان كل دول الخليج لها مصلحه
في استقرار
المجرى الملاحه في البحر الاحمر لانه ده
بيمر منه اكتر من عشره في الميه من
التجاره العالميه وجزء كبير من السفره
اللي بتعدي بتحمل بضائع للخليج او بتحمل
بترول الخليج وهذه الى اوروبا
فمش عاوزين
الفوضى اللي تحصل في السودان تنعكس على
فوضى في البحر الاحمر فتضرب مصالحهم في
التجاره العالميه
الامارات بقى عندها
هدفين تانيين ان عندها طموح اكثر من دول
الخليج الاخرى في ان هي تدير الموانئ او
تطور الموانئ الوااعده في السودان اللي
عنده اطلاله اكتر من 850 كيلو متر على
البحر الاحمر
ايضا الامارات سعه من 15 20 سنه ان هي
تكون اهم مركز لتجاره الذهب في العالم
وبدات ان هي
تطارد مصادر الذهب تعمل به ايه تستورده من
دول العالم
وتصدروا بعد تصنيعه او هي بورصه خاما او
مصنعا الى دول العالم الاخرى
2021 كانت صادرات الامارات وتحديدا دبي
حوالي 29 مليار دولار صادرات ده كان حوالي
سبعه ونص من كل صادرات العالم من الذهب في
هذا العام عشان تصدر ب 29 مليار دولار
يستوردته ما انتجتش الكميه دي استوردته
منين استوردته من 100 دوله منها السودان
اللي هو بيعد واحد من اكبر منتجه الذهب
فيه العالم
هذه هي مصالح السودان مصالح الامارات في
السودان
هل هناك تضخيم داء معتصم لحجم الصين
الحقيقي اقتصاد الصيني يعتمد بشكل كلي على
التصدير الدولي الغربيه
ولولا ايضا الشركات الغربيه التي تصنع في
الصين لماتت الصين جوعا لا انت اللي
بتبالغ في تقليل الصين يا اخوانا معتصم
الصين اللي انت بتقول عليه ده كان ينطبق
على الصين في يعني لغايه التسعينات اواخر
التمانينات اوائل التسعينات الكلام بتاعك
يبقى بيصف وضع الصين بالظبط وقتها انما في
السنوات اللي تالت في الثلاثين سنه اللي
فاتت وصولا الى الان
يعني الصين اصبحت عملاق حقيقي
كون ان هي بتعتمد على تكنولوجيا غربيه في
بعض الامور هي اصبحت دلوقتي ايضا بتصدر
التكنولوجيا بيعتمد عليه العالم المثل
الشهير والناس عارفاه التكنولوجيا الجيل
الخامس اللي اصبحت الرياده فيها للصين
كل تكنولوجيا الطاقه اللي هي النظيفه
اصبحت الرياده فيها للصين وليس للغرب الى
درجه انه في اعتقاد عند كتير من
يعني المنظرين الامريكان انه
وقت اللي هتنتهي فيه
الاعتماد على البترول والزائر والغاز
والفحم وينتقل العالم الى الثوره الخضراء
هتكون هذه المرحله التي تنتقل فيها زعامه
العالم الى الصين فانت اللي مقلل من الصين
كثير وبغض النظر عن التقليل
والتهوين الصين بتعتمد على الغرب في امور
وهو يعتمد عليها في امور انت بتقول لولا
ان الدول الغربيه بتصنع في الصين طب هي
الدول الغربيه بتصنع في الصين ليه ما هي
لو هي كانت موجوده في بلادها البيزنس
موديل بتاعها اختل هتبقى تكلفه انتاجها
مكلفه جدا الى الحد ان هي تفقد مزاياها
التنافسيه يعني
ما نقلتش للهند ليه ما هي ما قدرتش تلاقي
ان هذا النموذج ممكن يكون في الهند او في
اندونيسيا او غيره
استاذنا الكريم ماذا سيحدث للصين اذا
انتصرت اذا انتصر حلف النيتو على روسيا
بطريقه ما
يحدث هتبقى تغيرات كثيره الحقيقه يحدث انت
بتتكلم تنتصر يعني عرف معنى الانتصار
تنتصر يعني ايه يعني ان هي يهزم الجيش
الروسي ينسحب الجيش الروسي من اوكرانيا مش
عارف يسقط نظام بوتين ايه المقصود بكلمه
انتصار
لانه على حسب التعريف لو انت بتتكلم ان
روسيا تهزم وتتكسر وطبعا اذا روسيا خسرت
المعركه في او الحرب في اوكرانيا لن يبقى
بوتين هيحصل تغيير هتحصل فوضى في روسيا
يبقى بنتكلم ده كل تبيعات كثيره طبعا
فعشان نترك المجال سيناريوهات لازم نحدد
ايه المقصود بالخساره يعني هل سياسه
الولايات المتحده في الخليج
كل زياده في قوه الامارات وكل ضعف في قوه
السعوديه هو في مصلحتها
لا ليه يعني لا ليه يعني مش
مش شايف يعني بتصور على انه هم المشكله
بالنسبه لهم في السعوديه بس المشكله في
الامارات لا السعوديه
كان عاوز تقول للامريكان انت مشكلتكم معي
ايه يعني انا كنت حاليفكم خالص وما زالت
حليفه يعني عشان ما نبالغش في المساله كل
خطوه خدتها السعوديه تجاه
التقارب مع دول اخرى اولا هو تطور طبيعي
يعني السعوديه في سنه في الثلاثينات مع
نشاه الدوله مش هي السعوديه سنه 2023
وضع طبيعي يعني السعوديه بعدد سكانها اللي
تزايد بتجاربها السياسيه المختلفه ومش هي
بس عشان يعني الدول تغيرت يعني لا
السعوديه ليست بهذا الضعف الذي كانت عليه
في التمانينات والتسعينات مهياش بس دفتر
شيكات او اي تي ام لا اصبحت مختلفه
ولا الولايات المتحده ما زالت بقوتها بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه هكذا حركه التاريخ
يعني انما ارجع لسؤال حضرتك كل خطوه خدتها
السعوديه تجاه الرؤوس او تجاه الهند او
تجاه الصين هي جزء منها كان مدفوع
باستفزاز الامريكان
واعتبارهم ان السعوديه ودول الخليج
مهما اعمل فيكم انتم محتاجين يعني
لا انا مش معك في انه المشكله انه وبعدين
ما تنساش انه يعني
الامارات
دوله اداره ملفاتها بشكل جيد وكويس وشبكه
علاقات يعني تحسد عليها انما تظل السعوديه
هي الدوله الاكبر هي الدوله الاغنى وهكذا
يعني
السلام عليكم استاذ سيد وبالمناسبه في
خلافات كتير ما بين الامارات هو الولايات
المتحده يعني
بس ده موضوع يطول شرحه السلام عليكم استاذ
سيد الصين في 2021 حققت نموا في الناتج
المحلي بنسبه 8-1 في العشره واصبح
اقتصادها
17.7
تريليون دولار بعد ان كان 14 ونقول سبعه
من عشره تريليون سؤالي هو ازاي حسبنا نسبه
النمو حسبنا ازاي نسبه النمو ولا حسبنا
ازاي الناتج المحلي نسبه النمو بتتحسب
بيشوف الناتج المحلي الاجمالي زي مثلا في
سنه 2020
الاجمالي دوت الناتج المحلي الاجمالي اللي
هو القيمه النقديه لاجمالي ما انتجته
الصين من صلع وخدمات وبيقول انا انتجت
مثلا باليوان وليكن مثلا
100 تريليون يوان
طبعا كنا بتتحسب بالدولار دي قصه تانيه
يعني ان هو بعد كده بيحول اليوان للدولار
ده موضوع حسابي مش اكتر يعني ان هو مئه
تريليون يوان وبعدين بيجي العام التالي
اللي هو 2021 بيلاقي مثلا ان هو نسبه
النمو 110 تريليون جوان بيقول ان انا حققت
نسبه نمو 10% طبعا بيحسبها بطريقتين بس دي
قصه موجوده عندكم على نعم اقتصاد شوف كده
كيف يتم حساب الناتج المحلي الاجمالي مع
صديقنا الاقتصاد المحترم هاني جنينه فيها
اعتبارات فنيه وبيحسبها بالقيمه الاسميه
ولا بيحسبها بالريل جي دي يعني بشل نسبه
التضخم ولا لا بس دي التفاصيل ممكن ترجع
لها في الحلقه السابقه اللي هي موجوده على
نعرف اقتصاد انما باختصار بيشوف اجمالي ما
انتجه في 2020 ويشوف الزياده اذا تحققت
زياده وبيقول الزياده ديت فوق الميه بقينا
كنا ميه بقينا 110 يبقى الزياده عشره في
الميه كنا 100 بقينا وخمسه يبقى الزياده
5% اذا كان انا فهمت سؤالك يعني
هل تتفق انه في حاله انتصر محور الصين
ستترحم
ده معتصم بيقول انتصر محور الصين
سنترحم على امريكا سنصبح روبوتات لكل منا
رقم بالرغم من فضائح محور الولايات
المتحده الا اننا نستطيع ممارسه حريه
التعبير الحد الادنى ونوع ما يستطيع
الكثير
انا فهمت سؤالك يا معتصم معلش سامحني يمكن
عندي انا في عيني لان الخط صغير فيمكن ما
بقدرش اشوف كلام كتير لكن
شوف انا يعني اولا انا ما اعرفش انت ساكن
فين اذا كنت انت مواطن امريكي او عايش في
امريكا فطبعا اكيد جوده الحياه في امريكا
ونسبه الحريه اكبر من دول اخرى كثيره منها
الصين اما لو انت مواطن عربي عايش هنا
فانا مش عارف يعني يعني الولايات المتحده
تسمح لك بحريه التعبير فين الولايات
المتحده بتتعامل مع الحكومه اللي انت عايش
معها
والصين بتتعامل مع الحكومه اللي انت
عايشها
امريكا طول الوقت بتقول بضغط على الحكومات
من اجل حريه التعبير بس ده كلام يعني
هي ما بتاخدش اجراءات يعني تعمل فرق كبير
الصين بتقول انا ما ليش دعوه
تعملهم كويس تعاملهم وحش اناليه مصالحي
فاية في فرق على الاقل على الورق وفي فرق
برضو في التطبيق العملي ده صحيح لكن
للانصاف
واحده من الامور الجذابه في نموذج
الولايات المتحده عندها نموذج صيني
اقتصادي بيصدر مشاكل
عندها سياسه خارجيه اجريسه جدا جدا وجعلها
لا تضع السلاح على مدار 200 سنه انما من
مزاياها وما يجعلها قوه كبيره هو انه حتى
الان فيها احترام القانون واحترام الانسان
جوه امريكا خصوصا اذا كنت مواطن امريكي او
موجود بصفه شرعيه داخل امريكا تستطيع ان
تقاضي اي شخص وتحصل الى على حقوقك بشكل
كبير
تستطيع ان انت تعبر عن رايك وانت مطمئن
الى حد كبير هذا لا يحدث في دول اخرى
كثيره نقطه قوه للدوله الامريكيه وللدول
الغربيه حتى وانت اكلت هذه الحريه في
السنوات الاخيره لكن تظل هذا افضل ما لدى
الحضاره الغربيه حتى هذه اللحظه مقارنه
بمنافسها اذا كانوا الصين او روسيا يعني
امريكا ضعفت
وتجرا الكثيرون عليها من دول صغيره وكبيره
ولكن الحق يقال العم سام لم يضرب بيد بيده
الباطشه بعد لانه مازال يسوق لنفسه عن
طريق القوه الناعمه والله بيضرب بايده
الشمال وبايده اليمين يا اخونا والله ام
ار
تصدير الاكراد نفطيهم عبر ميناء البصره
بدلا من منا جيهان التركي واقتراب حلفاء
الولايات المتحده الدبلوماسي من سوريا
وايران هل هي سياسه العظمه والجزر اتجاه
ايران
لو انا مش فاهم السؤال بصراحه انت ربطت
اكتر من ملف في بعض لكن اذا انت قلت لي
انت اتكلمت عن ملف الاكراد وبعدين اتكلمت
على حلفاء الولايات المتحده الدبلوماسي مع
سوريا لا المساله مش يعني ملفات كتيره
وداخله فيها اعتبارات كثيره انما على
العموم انت بتتكلم على يعني مثلا لو خدنا
الجزء الواضح لنا قادر افهمه من سؤالك انه
تقارب حلفاء الولايات المتحده من سوريا من
سوريا وايران هي من سياسه وجزر اتجاه
ايران لا الدول دي اصلا عندها يعني ثقل
يعني هي يعني السعوديه
وتركيا دي برضو حارس امريكي متقارب مع
ايران وكل دول الخليج والامارات دي مش مش
حاجات نكره كده الولايات المتحده شايفاها
مجرد
جزء او ادوات في مواجهتها لايران يعني لا
هي الدول ديت عندها اولويات عندها
قدرات على الضغط الامريكي ما تقدرش امريكا
تتجاهله طوال الوقت يعني
الحان الوقت بان تعتذر الامارات لمصر بعد
تطبيعها مع اسرائيل ليه بقى تعتذر لها عبد
الرحمن يعني مصر بدات
معاهده السلام وان كان بصراحه هي لم تطبع
مع اسرائيل بالمعنى اللي عملته الامارات
الامارات عملت تطبيع حقيقي يعني مطاعم على
تناسب الديانه اليهوديه
معابد يهوديه تقارب اقتصادي انفتاح كبير
جدا تعاون استخباراتي امني وده مصر واشك
جدا جدا جدا انا ممكن تعمله في ال 100 سنه
اللي جايه انما هتعتذر لها للامارات
الامارات ليست مدينه لمصر امارات دوله
مستقله اخذت قرارها وقالت والله مصر سبقت
والامارات
والاردن تبعتها في سنه 74 وانا لي مصالح
وعملت ده يعني لا تدين بالتطبيع انا انا
لا اؤيد التطبيع وكنت اتمنى الا يتم بس
انا اتمنى ان انا عاوزه المهم شايفين
مصالحهم فين يعني
تحياتي استاذ سيد اين ترى تونس بعد خمس
سنوات من الان
انا اسف مش عارف اقرا الاسم يعني
لا ارى تونس انا سامحوني هم بيقولوا علي
متشائم انا
يعني واقعي انا بشوف نفسي مش متشائم ولا
حاجه الحمد لله على المستوى الشخصي يعني
وعلى يعني لا انا مش شايف مش متشائم ولكن
انت بتقول لي بعد خمس سنوات اذا صارت
الامور وعاده المستقبل بيكون امتداد
للحاضر لا تونس داخله على مشكله كبيره
تونس كل النخب فيها مشغولين بتصفيه
حساباتهم
وما حدش قادر لا قادر في طرف قادر يصفي
الطرف الاخر ويفرض تصوره ولا في نفس الوقت
قادرين ان هم يتعالوا على خلافاتهم
ويقولوا ان الشعب بيغرقوا البلد بتغرق
انا ما اقدرش اقول ان انا فقيه يعني في
الشؤون التونسيه لكن انا اتمنى حد من
التوانسه او من المتخصصين في الشان
التونسي يقول لي ايه وجهه نظر الرئيس
التونسي في ان هو مصر انه ياخد معارك ضد
كل القوى ضد النهضه والقضاء والشرطه
والاساتذه الجامعه مش قادر افهم اذا كان
كل هؤلاء شبكه واحده واذا كان كل دول
بيعبروا عن النهر ده يبقى النهضه من حقها
تحكم يعني اذا كنت انت بتقول كل دول هم
تغلغلوا وما زال بعد سقوطهم مش معقول فانا
ما اعرفش يمكن هو مفروض عليه كده يمكن
يعتقد انه
ده يتصور يعني يعني مرتبط برؤيته للامور
انا لا انتقده بقدر ما انا بضع علامه
استفهام مش عارف يعني هو فاتح جبهات مع كل
الناس مع كل الناس فانا مش قادر اتخيل
ازاي ممكن هو يتجاوز هذه الخلافات بتونس
ويقدر انه
يحل مشاكلها الاقتصاديه اللي بتتفاقم يوم
بعد يوم وبعدين هو مش عاوز يوقع مع
الصندوق انا فاهم بس ايه البديل صندوق
النقد ايه هو البديل هل الخليجين هيدولك
فلوس كثير من الدول مستنيه فلوس من الدول
الخليج ودول الخليج عندها اولويات اهم من
مساعده دول ممكن ما تستفادش منها كتير دول
الخليج عاوز تحط فلوس وتستفيد منها بلدك
مش مستقر هيدولك ليه هل انت مستني مثلا
كتله البكس مين كتله البريكس يعني الصين
بس هل الصين الصين عندها اولويات وبتضخ
استثمارات وفقا ليه مشروع الحرير ويعني
اللي هو سلك رود او الحزام والطريق زي ما
هم بيسموه ومش يعني هي عاوزه تستثمر في
معظم دول العالم تونس دوله صغيره من دول
كثيره يعني فمش عارف هي بتفكر ازاي او هو
بيفكر ازاي الاجابه على سؤالك اذا استمرت
الامور على هذا النحو تونس تبقى في وضع
اصعب مما هي عليه الان
اي الاطراف الاقرب للفوز في السودان ما
فيش حد فيهم اقرب للفوز انا عملت حلقه عن
السودان كانت ماده شارحه سريعه كده من
اسبوعين موجوده على القناه وقلت ان انا كل
اللي في اخر الحلقه بالضبط كل من تحدثت
اليهم
بيجزم ان المساله قريبه جدا وان الجيش سوف
يقضي على الدعم السريع خلال ايام انا كان
يقيني ان هذا كلام فيه تفاؤل كبير جدا جدا
جدا
لا يؤيده التاريخ لانه السودان ودول اخرى
دخلت في مواجهات معجمات مع جماعات اضعف من
الدعم السريع ومع ذلك استمر الصراع لسنوات
اتمنى طبعا ان لا يستمر لسنوات ولكن انا
كنت خايف حتى وقلت على كلامهم ان هذا يبدو
متفائل جدا وبالتالي المسائل مفتوحه وادي
احنا النهارده بنتكلم على اسبوعين تقريبا
والمسائل مفتوحه
الخوف ان هي تسمع في مناطق اخرى في
السودان ويحصل تماس مع قوه اخرى عندها
خلافات مع السلطه المركزيه
امريكا ضعف
محمد بيقول لماذا تدفع الولايات تدافع
الولايات المتحده عن وجودها في الجزيره
السوريه بكل هذه الحده ما اهميتها لامريكا
انا مش عارف بصراحه انا انا اقر بسؤالك
هذا طبعا انا عندي اجابه سريعه بس انت لما
تيجي تقرا الاجابه السريعه يعني باختصار
ان اسرائيل عاوزها تكون موجوده دول الخليج
عاوزها تكون موجوده
بعض الناس اللي هو اللوبي الاسرائيلي في
الولايات المتحده عاوزها تكون موجوده بعض
الناس المتمسكين بفكره ان امريكا لا يجب
ان تنسحب تمام بقطع النظر عن اسرائيل وعن
دول الخليج بيطلبوها وتكون موجوده انما هي
بصراحه ما فيش هدف واضح الهدف الواضح اللي
اعلنوه ان هم ينكدوا على الروس ويخلوا
سوريا بالنسبه لهم مستنقع ان هم يحاولوا
المشاركه في اجهاض التمدد الايراني في
سوريا دي الاهداف المعلنه لا اكثر ولا اقل
ان هم يدعموا حلفائهم الاكراد في مواجهه
اي اي تطور او ظهور مره اخرى للقاعده هذا
هو المعلن يعني
انما ما فيش حاجه في الجزيره يعني ما
تتخيلش ان في ثروه مثلا هم عايزين
يستحوذوا عليها السوريا ما هياش اولويه
للسياسه الخارجيه للولايات المتحده يعني
لماذا ياخذ النظام المصري خطوات حقيقه
لماذا لا ياخذ النظام المصري ده
[موسيقى]
او قاضي او محامي الى اخره ان الدوله ما
تعرفش تاخد خطوات حقيقيه للاصلاح ده غير
من وجهه نظر الحكومه الحكومه معتقده انها
منخرطه في برنامج اصلاح من 2014 وبدا بشكل
رسمي من 2016 فهي من وجهه نظرها انا ببذل
كل جهد للاصلاح النقدي
والمالي اللي هو يعني
تحديد القيمه العادله للجنيه واصلاح نظام
الضرائب وكذا وبدات في الاصلاح الهيكلي
نظام مصلحه التشريعات ومش عارف التعليم
وبدات في خطه فوجهه نظر حكومه انها بدات
هذا عن الحكومه انت بتقول بقى حقيقه تقصد
الافضل انك تقول حقيقي اذا سمحت لي يعني
طبعا انت قادره بسؤالك انك تقول فعال انه
يكون ليحقق نتائج لان المهمه صعبه جدا
اولا ففي اي دوله هي تاخد وقت طويل الامر
الثاني ان فعلا بعض الملفات الحكومه غير
جاده فيها وان الاصلاحات تمت بشكل صوري
ومتعجل وان هي اللي بينفذوا استجابوا الى
رغبه سريعه من الرئيس انه يعملوا اصلاحات
الان فيقولوا له حاضر يا سياده رئيسهم من
غير ما حد بيقول له ده ينفع ده ما ينفعش
السبب انه نظم في بلادنا بتخلي السلطه
دايما بتيجي من فوق للاسفل اسفل عاده ما
بيقدرش يتكلم ودائما خايف
لانه مثلا مش جاي من حزب منتخب فمسنود
باغلبيه جابته للبرلمان فيقدر يقول للرئيس
اه لا لا ده ما بيحصلش رئيس الوزراء بيكون
موظف كبير مش اكتر يعني اكتر حاجه يقدر
يعبر عنها بسبب الاحترام الشخصي للمؤهلات
اللي اتت به الى السلطه فيقدر الدكتور
مصطفى مدبولي يقول يا سياده الرئيس هذا
ممكن هذا مش ممكن في حدود انما هو ما
عندوش القدره مثلا زي في نظام منتخب
والدكتور مصطفى مدبولي جاي من حزب حصل على
اغلبيه في انتخابات حره نزيهه لا هم
مجموعه من الفنيين والمسؤولين يعني اصحاب
المهارات
تم تعيينهم من قبل الرئيس وبالتالي يقدر
يفصلهم يقدر يمشيهم
يعني
عاوزه سؤال لحميق بصراحه يعني انما
بتلاقي ان في حاجات كتيره بتصطدم باصحاب
مصالح ودي قصه قديمه تسبق الحكومه اللي
موجوده وتسبق السيسي تسبق مبارك اي دوله
عمليه الاصلاح فيها عنيفه انما انا اعتقد
ان في فرصه حقيقيه تم تم اطاعتها لانه في
2014 و2015 لما قال الرئيس السيسي كان
عنده رصيد يسمح له انه يبدا فعلا في عمليه
اصلاح رغم التحديات لكن يبدو انه المساله
ما كانتش بهذا الموضوع يبدو انه كان في
ثقه ان احنا نقدر نعمل الاصلاح اذا صرنا
فيه بهذا الشكل
انما مره ثانيه انه انا اقيدك في جزء من
السؤال ان هم ما قدروش ينتهزوا الفرصه
ويعملوا اصلاح فعال في وقت مناسب يعني
المساله طولت قوي
هل المطالبات من الشعوب العربيه بانهاء
اسرائيل امر منطقي امر منطقي لا مش منطقي
خالص غير منطقي غير منطقي معتصم دول يعني
بيقولوا كلام كده وبعدين ما حدش بيطالب
بانهاء اسرائيل على العموم يعني الكلام ده
كان زمان في الخمسينات والستينات
وجدي السلام عليكم هل برايك الدول العربيه
في الطريق الصحيح سياسيا وعسكريا
واقتصاديا طبعا يوجد دول قويه ودول اضعف
لك انت كلها هل يوجد نهضه وتلاحم برايك لا
لا توجد لا نهضه ولا تلاحم لكن في دول
بتدير ملفاتها بشكل احسن يعني
الدول الخليج محظوظه بعدد سكان صغير
وبثروه وبدا يبقى عندهم تراكم فقدرتهم على
اداره شؤونهم بقت افضل من دول اخرى كثيره
اما كل دول العجز اللي بتعاني من مشاكل
اقتصاديه زي مصر وزي تونس وزي المغرب
فيعني
مش بنفس القدره يعني ما عندهمش عندهم حجم
العجز والمشاكل
طاغي كبير جدا
تحياتي احنا ده كتير قوي بعد ما سبنا
اصدقائك لقينا ايه
لا
انا اسف هي جريت من الاسئله بس هرجع تاني
يعني محمد بيقول محمد البشير ما سر تحالف
اغلب القوه المدنيه قحت مع
المتمردتي هو قوى الحريه والتغيير اللي هي
قحط اللي بتقول عليها حضرتك لا هي
منقسمه اثنين
فصيل بيضم حوالي اربعين اللي وقع الاتفاق
الاطاري مع حمتي لانه اولا كان محتاج قوه
عسكريه تحميه من الجيش اللي هو
بيعتقده ان هو غير جد فيه انتقال
الديمقراطي وحمدتي كان في حاجه الى قوه
مدنيه تجعل منه او تبيض صورته من زعيم
ميليشيا الى رجل سياسه يعني وبالتالي راجل
عنده الجيش بتاعه لاقوات الدعم السريع
عنده امبراطوريه التجاريه فاضل عنده
القبول بقى السياسي عمل قبول شعبي بتبرعات
باعطاء سخن الله في 25 ابريل اعلن عن تبرع
بمليار دولار للحكومه السودانيه
وكان ما يحتاجه بقى انه القوى الثوريه
اللي كانت بتتهمو بارتكاب جرائم حرب في
بعد في يونيو 2019 ان هي تباركه وتعتبره
هو املها في الوصول الى الديمقراطيه وصلت
مدنيه وهو ده اللي حققه بس مش كلهم ولا
حاجه في ناس كتيره ضده
بحكم
نيه اسرائيل ده اخونا صقر او صفر انا اسف
مش عارف بحكم نيه اسرائيل التدخل
في السودان هل تتوقع تقسيم السودان مره
اخرى مساله مش واقفه على اسرائيل يعني انت
مد الاسرائيل اكثر بكثير من حجمها يعني
السودانيين قادرين يقوموا بالمهمه دي من
غير اسرائيل ويقسموا السودان من غير
اسرائيل ما تقلقش يعني هل ممكن تقسيم
السودان اه ممكن يحصل عمليه
تفكك تاني للسودان لانه الوضع كده دخل في
السيناريو سودوي
رينجرز لماذا نرى ان كل الدول التي نجحت
بازاله
ديكتاتورها لا زالت دول غير مستقره كاليا
والسودان وتونس واليمن بصراحه
لانه الدول عشان بتستقر بتحتاج عشرات
السنين بس احتاج عشرات السنين لو انت
بتعمل بشكل تراكمي
يعني مثلا
تجربه العراق
مش عاوز دول اوروبا لان دول اوروبا اللي
احنا دايما بنبص لها على انها يعني نموذج
جيد واستقر خدت 200 300 سنه يعني وبرضو
مذابح واحوال انما الدول العربيه تجربتها
كلها بدات تقريبا من الحرب العالميه
الثانيه كدول مستقله وفي دول بدات في
السبعينات ودول تورطت في حروب كثيره
محتاجه وقت كتير يعني انما برضو ردا على
سؤالك ايوه طبعا لانه الدول ديت عندها
مشاكل كتير يعني
تركيبه عرقيه وقبليه ودينيه متنفره علشان
يقعدوا يتفاهموا مع بعض ويقرروا ان هم
نقدر نتفاهم ويبقى في استقرار وتداول سلطه
عمليه تطور عثيره تحتاج الى عشرات السنين
والدكتاتور كان بيمثل ايه انت عندك اناء
او حله بتغلي هو حاطط الغطا فانت يبدو
الوضع كله مستقر بالقوه القهريه ما ان
يرفع الغطاء تلاقي بقى الغليان مستمر
هل هناك طيار شعبي في السودان ضد مصر ده
محمد جمال في حساسيه يعني حساسيه بس الناس
بيخافوا يتكلموا عنها
ويعني طبعا الكلام الرسمي مش هتلاقي
مسؤولين المصريين يتكلموا مش هتلاقي
مسئولين
سودانيين يتكلموا مش هتلاقي الصحف الكبيره
اللي بتعبر عن الحكومتين تتكلم بيخافوا
وبيقولوا المساله دي حساسه وهي فعلا حساسه
لكن في طيار ما عرفش اقول كبير جدا ولا
صغير لكن موجود للسودانيين عنده حساسيه
تجاه مصر لها اسباب تاريخيه باعتبار ان
جزء من هذا التيار بينظر الى مصر على انها
كانت دوله
محتله للسودان
وبينظر اليها ان هي حاولت استغلال السودان
وتوظيفه والاستفاده منه
يعني فالتيار ده موجود يعني ده كان في
تيار تاني كان بيدافع اصلا عن الاستمرار
في دوله واحده مع مصر يعني
لكن عموما يعني بانه قصه طويله ايوه في
تيار ما اعرفش حجمه لان ده ما فيش فيها
احصائيات عنده حساسيه كبيره تجاه مصر
وبرضو دي مش حاجه غريبه دايما الدول
القريبه اللي منكشف على بعضها وبينها
علاقات عميقه دايما بتكون الحساسيات بينهم
وبين بعض اكبر بكتير
الامثله بقى كتيره جدا شوف اوكرانيا
وروسيا شوف كوريا الشماليه كوريا الجنوبيه
شوف المكسيك والولايات المتحده شوف العراق
وايران
شوف دول الخليج
يا استاذ من فضلك
اترك الرد على الاسئله التي هي خارج موضوع
الحلقه
حاضر يا مدير انت ديكتاتوريا هنعمل ايه بس
يا منير ما هو الناس عندها اسئله
ومحمد البشير ما سر التحالف اغلب القوى
المدنيه قحط اجابنا لو سمحت يا ريت لو
بتتكلموا بقناه نعرف اقتصاد ما هو مدى خطر
الحروب الحاليه اوكرانيا وتايوان مثلا على
الاستثمار دي مش عاوزه حلقه اخونا عبد
الله اذا كنت بتتكلم على الاستثمار في هذه
الدول بالنسبه لتايوان دوله متماسكه او
بلد متماسكه عشان الصينيين ما يزعلوش دوله
دي بلد وعندها تطور كبير وعندها انتخابات
وعندها استقرار وعندها دعم غربي هائل فهي
مستقره انما لو انه الصين كثفت من حملاتها
وبدات يعني تحاصرها جوا وبحرا طبعا
الاستثمارات هتهرب كل واحد عنده راس مال
هيخاف عليه بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا مفيش استثمار انت بتتكلم على
بلد يعني بيتم تدميره فاكيد طبعا
الاستثمار عاوز استقرار فما فيش استقرار
في الحروب والتدمير
ما هو السبب عدم انقلاب العسكر في ايران
على الثوره كما فعلوا بالدول الاخرى لانه
يا صديقي لما جت
الثوره اولا الثوره الايرانيه والثوره
الاسلاميه الثورات نوعين
ثوره
اللي هي انا بسميها انصاف ثورات بتيجي
ثوره كده تفوضيه يعني واحد يعمل احتجاجات
ويتفاوض مع السلطه القائمه وفي ثورات
كاسحه
يعني ثوره 25 يناير اللي موجوده في مصر
مثلا كانت ثوره التفاوضيه الناس احتجوا
اطاحوا بالرئيس بشار الاسد اللي تحت
الاحتجاجات صار لكن الصغار عملوا ايه
بيتفاوضوا مع السلطه اللي في القلب منها
الجيش من فضلكم احنا عاوزين كذا يعملوا
احتجاجات الجيش يستجيب مره ما يستجيبش مره
دي ثوره تفويضيه وفي ثوره كاسحه زاد
الثوره الفرنسيه في التاريخ زي الثوره
الايرانيه مثلا 79 انه الطيار عنيف جدا
بيطيح بكل اجهزه الدوله وبتكون يعني
التغيير عنيف الثوره التفاوضيه مزاياها ان
العنف فيها قليل لكن نجاحها بيكون محدود
لانه بيتفاوض السلطه مع مع الثائرين
الدم قليل والانجازات قليله الثوره
الكاسحه الثوار بيحققوا كتير من مطالبهم
ولكن على حساب كم هائل من الدماء يعني
الثوره الايرانيه في عامها الاول على ما
اذكر قتل 40 الف في الشوارع
وطبعا استمر بقى حمام الدم في السنوات
المقبله لما جت الثوره حلت الجيش وحلت كل
الاجهزه لانها كانت لا تثق فيه وبسرعه مع
الوقت عملت
الحرس الثوري اللي كان جيش موازي واصبح هو
اقوى من الجيش العادي فما كانش عنده
القدره على انه هو
ينقلب على الثوره يعني لانه في جهاز موازي
ممكن يطيح بالجيش نفسه لاحظ ان الفكره دي
مثلا في الحاول البشير يكررها في انه يبقى
عنده قوات الدعم السريع اللي هي جيش موازي
للجيش اللي هو التقليدي
لماذا يا استاذ احنا العرب نحب الطغاه هل
ذا بسبب ثقافتنا يعني احنا ما بنحبش
التقابل ولا حاجه نفس البشريه بتحب الحريه
واكثر واحه اكثر حاجه يعني اكثر حاجه
انسانيه يعني او في علم النفس بيقولوا ان
ده موست امبورتن من اهم شيء الانسان بعد
الاكل والشرب اللي هي الغرائز الاساسيه
ويشعروا بالاهميه انك تحس ان انت ادمي انك
بتحترم فدي حاجات انسانيه ملهاش علاقه لا
بالعرب ولا غير العرب ولكن
يعني اولا
يعني هو عاوز يشعر بادم نيته لكن طبعا في
جزء منه زي ما قلت لحضرتك احنا دول حديثه
نسبيا
تاريخنا مع الاستقلال مش طويل
بتتكلم على حوالي 70 سنه ده قليل بالنسبه
للدول المستقره اللي بقى لها سنوات طويله
بدون احتلال كنا بنتكلم من شويه على الدول
اللي احتجت 200 300 سنه هل احنا محتاجين
300 سنه والله بيتهيالي كده يعني محتاجين
سنين طويله اذا بدانا خطوات سليمه يعني
كنا موبوين بدوله زي اسرائيل وحروب مختلفه
لكن اللي انت العنصر الحريق اشرت اليه
برضو هو عنصر صحيح يعني انت يعني ثقافه
فيها جزء انت عندك هنا نظام ابوي الرجل في
بيستاسد على الانثى الاب بيستاسد فيه على
الابناء الاخ الكبير يستاسد على صغره
انه مفيش حريه راي انت ما تقدرش يعني عيب
ان انت تكلم ابوك في الغالب يعني وتقول
رايي غير رايه يعني ممكن تستمحيه تستاذنه
انك تقول كذا عيب ان انت
زوجه واحد تقول له راي مخالف الا اذا كان
كده يعني من وراء ستار حتى لو كانت هي
صاحبه الكلمه بس قدام الناس لازم يكون هو
مش كده عنده لازم هو اللي يكون في الصوره
لثقافه ذكوريه دي ثقافه
يعني حراميه الدين بيلعب دور كتير لعبوا
مش عشان احنا بس مسلمين او الاغلبيه مسلمه
لعبت في كل الاديان ولذلك الكنيسه الحريه
بقت موجوده في اوروبا بعد ما ثار حصلت
حركه التنوير والكنيسه التلقي الضربات
كثيره مش معناه الناس ما يكونش متدينين
ولكن ما تنسوش ان الدين ده هو بيوصلنا من
خلال التفسيرات رجال الدين وكثير من رجال
الدين دايما مرتبط بالسلطه والسلطه مرتبطه
برجال الدين والقصه يطول شرحها الاسئله
العميقه ديت صعبه يا اصدقائنا في الله مش
عارف خايف الناس
اجبنا هذا السؤال
اجبنا هذه الاسئله نرجع تاني نمشي شويه
كده
احنا قدامنا اسئله كثيره
احنا ده الجزء اللي انا كنت خرجت منه
ايوه احنا كده ماشيين صح
ده جديد لماذا دول الخليج
تسعر الحرب في السودان وتسعر يعني تلهب
الحرب ولا تنظر لمصلحه السودان كدوله او
تقدم او تقدم استقرار السودان على المكاسب
الماديه لا يا اخونا علي خطاب ما تسلمش
دول الخليج كل الدول كده بتعمل كده مع
السودان يعني مش مشكله الدول الخليج اي
دوله بتدور على مصالحها هي المفروض يعني
انه حاكم اللي موجود في الامارات ولا في
مصر ولا في تشاد ولا في اي دوله بيدور على
مصلحته هو يعني هو مصلحه شعبه
انما مش مصلحه السودانيين فانت بتتكلم على
وضع مثالي غير موجود
ولا تصدق ان في دوله لا تتدخل في الدوله
الاخرى كل الدول يعني حصل كارثه في سوريا
ماشي خلاص ممكن يقدم لها مساعدات بس يعني
في الاخر عاوزين مقابل هذه المساعدات كل
دوله تتدخل اكثر حاجه ممكن تقدمها لك انك
توصل معها لصيغه بس عشان توصل معها انت
تفوزه وهم يفوزوا لازم انت تكون قائم على
رجليك ودوله مستقره وقادر على التفاوض لكن
لو كانت الدوله سايبه وفيها انفلات ولما
الدوله بتنفلت اصلا النخب بيدوروا على
مصالحهم الخاصه وبالتالي ما تظلمش دول
الخليج يعني هذا موقف دول الخليج وغيرها
الدول العظمى ده ال بيقول الدول العظمى
اصبحت ست من الماضي والظل من صورتها
السابقه حتى امريكا لم يعلن لم يعد
لم يعلن لم يعد يترشح لرئستها شخصيه قويه
بعد نكبه بوش متى سينتهي النظام العالمي
الحالي وما هي الدول العربيه التي تتوقع
ان تكون ستكون دوله عظمى شوف الكلام اللي
انت بتقوله انه الدول العظمى بقت اصبحت من
الماضي ده بيعبر عن تراجع نفوذ الغرب بصفه
عامه انما في دول عظمى الصين طالعه اهي ده
اللي احنا بنتكلم عليه
فكره ان ما فيش رؤساء عندهم يعني
يعني شخصيات قويه زي ما انت بتقول ده كان
فكره ليه كمان عبر عنها فكره موجوده يعني
بس عبر عنها يا فريد زكريا اللي هو الصحفي
الامريكي الهند الاصلي عبر عنها انا اظن
في كتاب انا اسمه تايه من ذهني ولكن عبر
عن فكره انه بقى في شورتدج او في نقص في
الزعامات الملهمه يعني في الغرب
وخلاصته كده برضو انه ده نتيجه تدهور
الغربي يعني انما الجزء التاني من سؤال
حضرتك ايه الدول اتوقع العربيه اللي توقع
ان تكون هناك تكون هي دوله عظمى لا اتوقع
ان تكون هناك دول عظمى الدوله العظمى لها
مكونات جغرافيه وسكانيه وعلميه لازم تكون
متوفره الاول وهذه لا تتوفر فئه دوله
عربيه
مصطفى لو مصر فعلا من الحلف الشرقي مع
الحلف الشرقي الصين وروسيا السؤال هنا ليه
روسيا بتدعم حميدتي
وبتفتح حرب على حدود مصر لا يا صديقنا
الامور ما بتمشيش استاذ مصطفى على كده
اولا مصر مش في الحلف في الشرقي مصر زي
دول اخرى من دول ما يسمى بالجنوب العالمي
او اللي احنا كنا بنقول عليه الدول
الناميه لا ترغب في ان تكون
رهينه لدوله واحده اصبحت
تصرفاتها مش مضمونه وهي بصراحه عمرها ما
كانت يعني لفتره طويله قوي في المعسكر
الامريكي
يعني ما كانتش في الخمسينات مثلا
والستينات ده كانت
لو افترضنا ان بدايه من الستينات او من
بعد اتفاقيه السلام
بقينا صحيح في المعسكر الامريكي بشكل
اذانا كثيرا او اذى مصر يعني لو انا بتكلم
بشكل محايد انما مصر برضو ليست في المعسكر
الشرقيه ما زالت على علاقه قويه جدا
بالامريكان وما زالت هناك يعني ملفات
كتيره للتعاون بين الاتنين انما اللي
عملته مصر واللي بتعمله دول عربيه اخرى هي
تنويع المصادر يعني او تنويع التحالفات
بتعمل عمليه زي ما بيحصل في الاقتصاد تكون
على العلاقه بامريكا لكن ليس علاقه حصريه
بامريكا ليه بقى هم على العلاقه القويه
بروسيا وفي نفس الوقت روسيا بتدعم حماتي
اولا حكايه روسيا ابتدا بحمدت ديت محتاجه
مناقشه ومع ذلك ده مش امر غريب ابدا ان
دولتين يكونوا اصدقاء ويكون لكل منهم تصور
مختلف
في ملف ما استاذنك لو انت عاوز تعرف تصور
القصه ديت انا كانوا ومازال مصر على ان في
حلقه انا عملتها من حوالي سنتين اسمها
كيف تفهم العلاقات الدوليه
بكلمه واحده او اعقد العلاقات الدوليه
بكلمه واحده وكانت هذه الكلمه هي كلمه
فرندي يعني صديق وكلمه انمي يعني عدو في
كلمه بالانجليزي اسمها يعني الصديق العدو
اللي هي بتعبر في العلاقات الدوليه عن ايه
انه
دوله حليف حليف معاك في كل حاجه ودي حاجه
نادره يعني ودوله عدويه عدويه يعني ممكن
تحاربها انما في دوله غريبه كده هي انت
على العلاقه كويسه معها في الملفات
وتعاديها في ملفات اخرى والدول بتتعايش مع
بعض بتتقبل ده وفي القصه ديت امثله كتيره
جدا جدا جدا جدا يعني هنا في الدول
العربيه كتير يعني الامارات ومصر مثلا
اصدقاء انما يختلفوا في الملف الاثيوبي
والنبي يختلفوا في الملف السوداني
انما ممكن يختلفوا في ملفات تانيه اختلفوا
في الملف الاسرائيلي وهكذا تركيا وروسيا
وهكذا يعني فده امر مالوف جدا
العقوبات الاقتصاديه على روسيا وتاثيرها
على الاقتصاد العالمي
هتقسم العالم كله الى فسطاطين لان
العقوبات على روسيا بدات تطال دول اخرى
والعقوبات مش على روسيا بس العقوبات
بتتصاعد على الصين فيبقى عندك العالم
يفسروا سور عظيم كده زي ايام الاتحاد
السوفيتي
والغرب ايام الحرب البارده ما مصير
اللاجئين السوريين في لبنان
كان الله فيهم اللاجئين السوريين في ورطه
لا هم قادرين يعيشوا في لبنان ولا هم
عارفين يرجعوا بلدهم ايه مصيرهم مصيرهم
مرتبط بتسويه الصراع السوري كله
محمد
ما سره تحالف اغلب اجابنا لماذا يا استاذ
احنا اجابنا
هل انقلاب السودان بواعظ امريكي لانهاء
العالم عن هزيمته في اوكرانيا لا يا صديقي
المشكله التوتر في السودان ناجم عن مشاكل
داخليه
انما الدول الخارجيه تبتدي تتدخل في
الفتره المقبله يعني
لماذا الدول اجابنا
المرجع بيقول هناك دراسه باستخدام نشاط
استخدام الكهرباء حول العالم عن ان الناتج
القومي في الصين اكبر ب 30% من حقيقته وان
النمو السنوي اقل بدرجتين عن المعلن لان
الحكومه الصينيه هي المصدر الوحيد لارقام
الناتج القومي
يكون العجوزه صدقنا واضح ان انت عارف
المساله وعارف تفاصيل انا لست مطلعا على
هذه التفاصيل يعني انا بتكلم على المساله
في العموم ان انت عشان تعرف بقى التفاصيل
حساب الناتج المحلي الاجمالي في دوله لازم
يكون عندك الدق التفاصيل عن هذه الدوله
كان في حد طالب انه
يعني
نرشح له حد يتكلم عن مساله حساب الناتج
المحلي القومي الاجمالي يعني وده جزء من
اسم جزء من علم اسمه الحسابات القوميه
فسعيت يعني ان انا اسال زيتي اللي هم
متخصصين في القصه ديت فواحد منهم
ابعتلي رساله قال لي القصه اللي انت
بتقولها ديت عاوزه مش ناس كتير يتكلموا
فيها والاهم ان هو لو هيتكلم في الجزائر
هو كان للجزائر يعني في ندوه في الجزائر
لازم يكون مطلع بشكل كبير جدا جدا على
تفاصيل مش بس اي كلام نظري يعني واضح ان
انت قاري انا مش ما عنديش تفاصيل دي عن
الاقتصاد
الصيني يعني بحكم
نيه اسرائيل اللي اجمناه
لك مني تحيه وسلام يا استاذنا العزيز من
اهل العواميه
ده علي ومن القطيف بالمنطقه الشرقيه
بالسعوديه انت لنا
عزه وكرامه لطيبك وصراحتك وتعاملك بما هو
واقع وصريح تحيه لك من زملائك
تحيه لك والى زملائك ربنا الطيبين ربنا
يخليك شكرا جزيلا علي انا لما بتهت في
القرايه مش لان انت كاتب حاجه غلط لان انا
بس يعني ايه العتب على النظر انا شاكر جدا
لرسالتك الحلوه
وبشكرك بالنيابه عن ماندو
منذ سنتين يتحدث الغرب عن ضروره تحويل
الوطن العربي الى مركز صناعي قريب يوفر
حاجتهم ماذا تعرف عن ذلك لا اعرف اي شيء
يا صديقنا في الوطن هو يعني
الوطن
يعمل مشروعاته فين هيعملها في السودان
مثلا هل هيعملها في سوريا هل هيعملها فين
في لبنان هل هيعملها في اليمن هو ممكن
يفكر في الدول القريبه المستقره زي
الجزائر زي المغرب زي زي مصر
ممكن يستغل ان هم عندهم كمان مصادر طاقه
عندهم مصادر طاقه متجدده ومصادر طاقه
احفوريه وقريبين من البحر الاحمر ممكن بس
المساله مش بالسهوله دي حتى لو الاموال
متوفره من الاتحاد الاوروبي المشكله ان
تكون البيئه مهيئه انت عشان تضخ استثمارات
بتقول انا هحط استثمارات قد ايه واحد
لازم يكون البلد امن عشان يكون البلد امن
مش بس انه الناس ساكته وبتاع لازم تكون
البلد مستقره بيعمل دراسته كده بيقول
البلد ده مش معرض لهزات او حروب لسنوات
يعني لازم يكون في ناس مؤهله ايدي عامله
مؤهله والا انا هجيب اعمل استثمارات مثلا
فرنسيه واجيب مهندسين كلهم من فرنسا ما
لازم ايدي عامله لازم تكون بنيه تشريعيه
جيده لازم حاجات كتير لازم بنيه تحتيه
مكتمله فالحاجات دي كلها بيخليهم يفضلوا
يطلعوا على الصين تاني يعني
او دول اسيويه قريبه
استاذ سيد
ده اخونا سيد
بشكرك على محاوله تقديم المعلومات بحياد
وبدون ادخال توجهاتك الشخصيه
وبسال في غياب فرص الحل في السودان اي طرف
اي الطرفين سيكون فوزه في رايك افضل
بالنسبه للسودان اولا وبالنسبه لدول
المنطقه ثانيه
والله هو سؤال صعب سؤال صعب بصراحه
يعني ما يتوفر الي من المعلومات وانا ما
عنديش كل المعلومات لكن انا بستنتج يعني
من حديثي مع السودانيين والسودانيين عندهم
ميزه يعني
عندهم كم كبير جدا من الناس اللي هم
متعلمين تعليم
يعني هم كده يبدو ان هم طبيعتهم عندهم ناس
كثيره عندهم قدره على القرايه والاستنتاج
والتنظير يعني على العموم
انت عندك قوتين اتنين بنتكلم عليهم والقوه
المدنيه هتبقى منحزه لواحد منهم القوه
المدنيه لوحدها مش هتقدر تعمل حاجه يعني
غير ان هم منقسمين على انفسهم اساسا يعني
قوى الحريه والتغيير اذا اعتبرناها هي
المظله الكبيره هي منقسمه الى معسكرين
والداخل كل معسكر في انقسام الحريه
الدعم السريع انا لا اعتقد ابدا ان
بتاريخها وتركيبتها يمكن ابدا ان تقود
فعلا مع عوافر الاحترام للسيد حمدان ديجلو
اللي هو عنده قصه كفاح بغض النظر عن ان
ناس بيتهم ان هو جزار وناس بيتهم انه راجل
عصامي في النهايه هو راجل
رحله الصعود وكزعيم له ميليشيا صعب جدا ان
يكون رئيس دوله يباركه المجتمع الدولي
وحتى اذا باركوا ايكون نتيجه القوه لكن
صعب قوي انه يعني يمهد لنفسه على اعتبار
ان انا يعني زعيم وطني وعاوز انتقل الى
الديمقراطيه هذا كلام مش ممكن ينطلع على
احد على السودانيين قبل العالم الخارجي
الجيش السوداني عنده مشكله يعني واضح اولا
انه حتى هذه اللحظه هو
تاخر كثيرا في علاج في حاجتين اولا في حسم
موقفه واضح ان هو كان راغي غير راغب فعلا
في عمليه اي انتقال ديمقراطي وان كان عاوز
يكسب وقت وده كان واضح من اول لحظه تم
فيها تنحيه البشير ما فيش ادل على كده انه
اول مرشح انه يتولى المجلس العسكري اللي
هيقود السودان كان اظن الفريق عبد الرحمن
عوف وانا فاكر كلمه عوف بس احنا مش متاكد
الاسم الاول يا ريت حد من السودانيين
يفكرني
الراجل ده كان اختياره حاجه غريبه جدا يدل
على انه الجيش وقتها يا اما مرتبكه يا اما
بيسخر من السودانيين السودانيين طالبوا
باسقاط البشير فياتي الفريق عوف اللي هو
ايه اخوان
ونسيب تربوعه تربيته علاقه نسب بالبشير
فيعني هل هذا يعقل وكان اصلا على راس
المؤسسه العسكريه فيعني
فانت بتقول لي الاقرب اذا كان ولابد من
الاختيار هتبقى القوات المسلحه السودانيه
يعني الاقرب الاقرب يعني
لو المؤسسه العسكريه قدرت فعلا ان هي
تتفاهم بدل عمليه القضاء الكامل على الدعم
السريع ده كلام صعب انه يتم لو قدرت
الوساطه انها تفلح ولو قدر ان هو يبتدي
فعلا يسلم بانه مش قادر ينفرد بحكم
السودان وقدر انه
يقود عمليه مفاوضات تستمر سنتين ثلاثه زي
ما كان مخطط ممكن يكون في امل انه
الجيش السوداني اقرب من غيره الى انه
يتفاهم مع القوه المدنيه الاخرى
لماذا دول الخليج لاجبنا ده محمد الشيخ
بيقول منور اخي العزيز والصحفي القدير سيد
جبيل ربنا يخليك يا محمد انت محمد الشيخ
الصحفي لو كنت انت يعني اشارلي ربنا يخليك
ويسعدك
هل ما زال هناك من يمكنه اتهام الاسلاميين
هل ده تاج هل هل مازال هناك من يمكنه
اتهام الاسلاميين وقد راينا وما زلنا نار
الى يومنا الوف الامثله عن العلمانيين
وشرالاتهم الذين هم امراء الحرب الحقيقيين
الذين قتلوا وشردوا هجروا الشعب هم سبب
فقرها وتخلفها والله انت بتظلمهم يا
اخوانا التاج يعني سؤالك بصراحه بيعبر عن
موقف منحاز ايه علاقه العلمانيين بالقصه
يعني انت مشكله السودانيين انه الفريق
حمدتي علماني يعني يعني ايه علماني الاول
انا انا مش بقول لك ان انت مش عارف لا سمح
الله بس انا اقول لك يعني لما تعرف
الجيش على انه هو علماني او الفريق حميدتي
على انه علماني معناها انه راجل بيقول
علمانيه السياسيه ما هو في العلمانيه لها
تعريفات كثيره علماني ده واحد احد تعريفات
انه لا يؤمن بالدين كله على بعضه
السودان مش ممكن تبقى فيها علمانيه ناجحه
بهذا المعنى شعب زي معظم الشعوب العربيه
يعني يتغلغلوا التصوف والتدين والجماعات
فمش ده المقصود يعني
انما العلمانيه بالمعنى السياسي ان انا
بقول انه والله انا عاوز انه تكون الدوله
لا دين لها يعني ايه لا دينا لها يعني
تحترم كل الاديان وان المؤسسه لا تتبنى
وجهه نظر معينه وانها تحترم اليهود
والمسيحيين والكذا وكذا وان هي تترك
الحريه
للاغلبيه تقرر مع احترام الاقليه تيجي
الاغلبيه مسلمه تقول والله انا عاوزه احكم
الشريعه الاسلاميه مثلا في كل
الحاجات الاسريه على عين وراس انا عاوز
والله امنع بقانون الخمور يقول له طب اوكي
طب انا عاوزه اكبر المسيحيين اقول له لا
ما ينفعش بقى كده انا عندي هنا والله هم
احرار طب انا عندي كذا انا اسمح له ولكن
ممكن امنع مثلا الخمور في اماكن عامه كذا
ممكن اسمح بها بيبقى في عمليه مفاوضات هل
دي ايه مشكله الفريق حمدتي هل دي مشكله
الفريق برهان هي العلمانيه يعني ترسلي دول
ناس عسكريين او
حرب سواء في السودان او غيرها طمحين في
السلطه لا مشكلتهم لا الدين ولا مشكلتهم
العلمانيه بالمعنى اللي انا بقول عليه ولا
مشكلتهم الحريات مشكلتهم مصالحهم الخاصه
والفئويه والجهويه لا اكثر ولا اقل فلا
تظلم يعني العلمانيه انا عندي ايمان
يعني بيتراكم بالسنين ان العلمانيه هي
العلمانيه بالمعنى اللي انا فاهمه
العلمانيه دي هتحرم واحد مسلم متدين جدا
من ان هو يطبق الشريعه كما يراها ده صحيح
وهيصطدم بفكرته انه ان الحكم الا لله اذا
كان ده ايمانه انما سوف تسمح للمسلم في
الهند وفي الهند دي فيها 250 مليون وفي
سريلانكا وفي كل دول العالم يعني وفي
الصين حيث يضطهد المسلمون هي تحميق
عبادتهم تحمي فرصهم للترقي تحمل مسيحيين
اللي عايشين هنا تحمي اليهود احنا غلطنا
اصلا بان احنا لم نحترم اليهود ايامه
كانوا هناك لو كنا احترمناهم ولم نهاجمهم
في بعض الدول ما هاجروا الى اسرائيل
واصبحوا عدوا لنا وكانوا بقى موجودين
يهودي زي مسلم وزي مسيحي قصه يطول شرحها
ولكن
الخلاف في الوقت لا يفسد الوده قضيه ولا
تعتقدوا ابدا ابدا ابدا انه اللي بيدافع
عن العلمانيه السياسيه بالمعنى اللي
يقولوا ان هو راجل كافر اللي بيكره الدين
هو بيقول لك ايه الحل في دوله حديثه فيها
اديان مختلفه تعمل لهم ايه هتقول لي والله
انا موجود في السودان انا عندي اغلبيه
مسلمه النتيجه ان انت خسرت جنوب السودان
ما انت كنت احد اسباب جنوب السودان في
اسباب سياسيه وكذا بيقول له انت عاوز تخلي
المواطن العربي المسلم مواطن رقم واحد
والباقي مواطن رقم اثنين فالنتيجه ان انت
خسرت جنوب السودان ماذا لو عاش معك
الجنوبيين بكل ديانتهم ومنحتهم حقوقهم
وكذا وبتاع كان ايه اللي حصل لك يعني
وهل انت كنت صادق يعني في تطبيق الشريعه
كانت مشكله النمير يا تطبيق الشريعه ولا
برضو نوع من مغازله الناس
اوكي
الدول العظمى اصبحت
لماذا يا استاذ احنا اجبنا
نحن في لبنان ننتظر كلمه من الخارج
لانتخاب رئيس الجمهوريه فهل صحيح ان هناك
غرف عمليات في دول الخارج السعوديه وايران
وامريكا خاصه لمناقشه مستقبل هذا البلد
الصغير الليله ليس الذي ليس له تاثير على
العالم لتاثير
ده فداء ازاي لبنان زي ما
صداقتنا الصحفيه المحترمه سوسن الابتح مره
بتقول لي صحفيه لبنانيه يعني في الشرق
الاوسط بتقولي احنا اللبنانيين قد الفاره
ونملا الحاره يعني صغير ولكن يعني مؤثرين
لا طبعا
بس يعني الوضع في لبنان مرتبط زي ما قلت
لحضرتك بتسويه اوضاع كبيره
بالصراع بالدرجه الاولى مع ايران
سواء الدول المنطقه او اسرائيل او
الولايات المتحده بتحلل مشكله مع ايران او
تهدا النظام ان شاء الله في لبنان وطبعا
المشكله في سوريا
تحيا الجزائر شامخه ماشي يا صديقنا تحيا
الجزائر ده مصطفى بولو هل انقلاب السودان
بيواعظ
امريكي لالهاء العالم عن هزيمتها في
اوكرانيا
لا يا صديقنا لا احنا اجابت عن السؤال ده
هل يمكن فنيا ضرب سد النهضه بحيث
ان يتم اخراجه من الخدمه دون تدميره تماما
لم يحدث
لا يبدو انه وارد انا مش يعني ما اعرفش
حاجه عن الحكومه المصريه انا يعني لست
صحفيا لا اعبر عن الحكومه المصريه لكن هذا
الكلام وفقا لمعلوماتي يتاخر الوقت كثيرا
لا يناقش في حدود معلوماتي بجديه
ولا اعلم ان هناك حلول جذريه يعني ممكنه
في الامد القريب غير محاوله
الضغط على الحكومه الاثيوبيه لتفهم مطالب
المصريين وطبعا اذا لم تستقر الاوضاع في
السودان فده يضر الموقف المصري
ما هي تداعيات عوده الدول العربيه الى
سوريا بعد قطيعه 11 سنه استاذنك في حلقه
كامله ان شاء الله هعملها انا كنت يعني
شغال عليها وجاءت الاحداث في السودان حاضر
لكن
رده سريعات عوده الدول العربيه هي لسه ما
عدتش يعني لان في دول ما زالت بترفض ليه
بترفض قصه طويله بس انا اسف لو قلتها
دلوقتي ممكن ناخذ لنا نص ساعه يعني هل
تعتقد ان فرنسا طرف فيه يعني انت عندك
السعوديه بقت هي اللي بتقود محاوله اقناع
الدول العربيه بالتطبيع لكن ما زالت قطر
عندها تحفظ المغرب عندها تحفظ اليمن عندها
تحفظ الكود بتقول لازم كله يوافق الاول
قبل ما يوافق
واللي موقف اللي انا مش فاهمه هو الموقف
المصري والله
هل تعتقد انا فعلا مش فاهم يعني مش بستنكر
مش فاهم والله انا حتى كنت بكلم حد قبل
التسجيل يعني انما انا مش لاقي رد واضح
ايه هو الموقف المصري في دولتين انا ما
بفهمش موقف مصري لا سوريا ولا ايران لو حد
يعني مين اللي بيتابعني واللي بيتابعني
كتير من الاساتذه المحترمين اللي عندهم
خبرات يتواصل معي ويقول لي ايه هي
معلوماته ايه هي الموقف المصري من سوريا
وايران اكون شاكر
هل تعتقد ان فرنسا طرف في صراع السودان او
ستدخل اليه خصوصا
[موسيقى]
وجد الذهب هناك ما هي فرنسا دوله كبيره
يعني داخله في ملفات كتيره بس